honest reaction Wow
we're going there all right well I'm
gonna take another drink
good thing I don't have to drive hello
welcome back to interviews under the
influence I'm Sophie Scholl AC here
today with princess Ashanti and we've
got Ciroc french vanilla in the house
[Music]
this is the princess cocktail princess
cocktail it's not too heavy it's cute
it's sexy its light and it tastes good
Cheers
cheers girl thanks for being here okay
so we have to talk about this Ciroc
partnership and the bikini that broke
the internet okay let's start there cuff
and I had been talking for a while and
he's like I want you to have the both
Derek moment when I finally got the kini
you know it's all crystal II and I'm
like it was it was amazing give me some
of your secrets to being in that kind of
shape um honestly you really do have to
watch what you eat
it matters I'm a big believer in juicing
like I do one of my many secrets I will
tell you okay celery cucumber ginger and
a tiny bit of coconut water right in the
blender I promise you you like in like
four days and that is how you break the
internet folks hey you've got a new
single out say laughs yeah let's talk
about Salem
[Music]
me and I were texting back and forth for
a while I loved his melodies and for me
it's just really important to kind of
get have a chemistry well we kind of
just hit it off automatically and what
can you tell us about your next
full-length this is by far the most
vulnerable most risque
most risk but all my guts out on the
table haha kind of record
okay album I don't know I just felt like
it was time to go there yeah are you
spilling tea honey this is hot the
kettle is overpowering yeah hey some
some feelings are gonna be a little hurt
now if you've seen this series before
you know the rules if I'm gonna ask the
questions here if bhishan tea wants to
answer I will go ahead and take a drink
if you want to plead the fifth you can
go ahead and take a big ol sip butter
egg and say that say that now you and
Joe are heading out on tour yes
[Music]
I love the enduring friendship that you
guys have oh you're the question though
have you ever crossed the line into more
than friends absolutely not never never
never
you're never tempted I don't know what
it was with us to like from the first
time we met it was like oh my sister and
we shot a video together and he was just
doing like brother stuff like you know
pushing me out the way yeah I mean like
it was crazy so it's always been like
that everyone in our office was so
excited to see you guys together on the
Hamilton mixtape Lin actually had his
people reached out to us and told us
backstage after we saw the play that he
was inspired by John and I Hamilton and
Eliza was inspired by us what yeah and
when me and John went to see the play we
went backstage I was just like oh my
gosh that's crazy so he was like really
emotional just seeing both of us it's
like his vision came to life it really
really was such a moving experience
because for him to say that you know
we've inspired the play is crazy I'm not
just any play exactly Hamilton Hamilton
haha and I'm not gonna lie
both of us were like old clothes I mean
it doesn't make sense but both of us
were very pleasantly surprised how he
thought it was gonna be late it was
amazing he's a genius yeah has he asked
you to be in it I mean the girl who
inspired the character hello no no no no
would you do it though you know I had my
run I did the whiz Broadway and it is
very time-consuming yeah like that's
that's what you eat sleep and breathe
and activity continue to camp
okay farewell drink that's a great story
mm-hmm so speaking of Ashanti the
actress one of my favorite movies is
John Tucker Must Die John
tacker hey sorry
let's tell me a secret story from the
set oh I have a lava see it's got to be
juicy at the time the person that I was
dating was sneaking up there to Canada a
lot snake it wasn't supposed to be
happening but it was happening did you
ever get caught kind of not really
really full started to no because
they're like a bunch of roses being
delivered to my room wait but why
weren't you allowed to have your
boyfriend with you because it was just
like a distraction kind of a thing okay
and I'm super private you know what I
mean so you know yeah okay no rule
breaker I like it john loves girls on
top of the pyramid
hello now I got to throw it back to 2003
for this question
what was your honest-to-god reaction
when you saw that infamous New York
Times Beyonce review honest reaction wow
we're going there I was just like wow
you know it was it was super flattering
what I didn't like so much is that the
media has a way of pitting people
against each other of course her and I
had always had a very cool camaraderie
it's always like hey what's up how you
doing hey I like your sneakers come not
wired that way if I don't like you I
don't like you I could hate you and
still like your record you know what I
mean and vice versa and I'm too happy
with myself to just be an envious kind
of a person sure I mean what is your
favorite but also what is your least
favorite song that you've ever recorded
the one that comes to the top of my head
now is rescue which was on my first
album time I remember at the time CEO of
my label was trying to make me give it
to JLo and we had like a fight because I
was like no I already gave a record that
I love to take home
what am i least why happy and baby real
I always said baby was too low and they
were like now I survived it survived ok
they ended up all being right I actually
do like it one of the songs I don't like
to that is my next question actually and
I will tell you most people don't answer
it so I love that you rock with you yeah
and that's a big record I don't know
what it is
hmm my mom and my DJ they yell at me and
they forced me to put it back in the
show
[Music]
now this is one that I asked everybody
who does this segment okay tell me the
most Awkward encounter you've ever had
with another celebrity this was a good
one I was on the way to the Grammys and
Patti LaBelle was in the hallway she
came up to me singing always on time she
gave me a hug and she's like oh and she
lifted it up and she's like oh cool
let's fix this statue
she had her makeup artist come over and
tape double-stick tape my boob into my
dress in the lobby of the fastest story
I've ever heard of Shante it was the
most amazing and awkward celebrity
meeting ever it was hilarious oh my gosh
and I love her okay so you you kind of
touched on this earlier but you've been
really open about the drama surrounding
the whole thing with JLo and the song
that you loved that you had to give away
is that something that you and JLo ever
talked about no I was not officially
signed to a label I was young mm-hmm and
this was like the test you know what I
mean they're like oh we're gonna test
her who really writes these records and
you know who's not gonna want to give a
record - JLo though but um it's a
business thing you know what it means
there's a lot of money made those I
guess there any other song that got away
for you yeah um it was Eve and Alicia
Keys I just wanna rock
[Music]
they asked me if I wanted to do that
first and I don't know I don't know what
I was on happen but that was a great
record yeah when you heard it on the
radio when you started hearing it on the
radio were you like oh man
okay so transitioning um what is your
current relationship status Salus you
gotta take your drink girl oh man I
thought we were gonna break a record and
I was gonna do all the drinking and you
were gonna do none okay
now I've gotten a lot of questions
within the office they want to know if
you and your ex still talk ever
nelli know what I would say is sometimes
there are messages transpired through
other people I still suck these parents
though you do yeah I actually spoke to
his death this much they always say to
let them know when I'm on TV okay so you
still hold the Guinness World Record for
most albums sold by a debut female
artist yes which is incredible like
Grammy winning goddess over here
Guinness World Record
what's another Guinness World Record
that you would want to go for that one
is Gemini well then you take a little
drink
hahaha I don't have to drive it's been
15 years since the debut came out can
you believe that first of all I cannot
it's crazy like insane and girlfriend
still looks phenomenal for the record
this is all natural - so what advice
would you give yourself
15 years ago looking back who what I
will say is I probably would have gotten
away bigger advance and I know are you
gonna break these risk I definitely
wouldn't say a few more zeros attached
to that where my crystal ball have been
nice crystal ball yeah so that is my
last question yeah
so let's look at the difference here Wow
yeah the difference I'm feeling it a
little bit I hope you don't have to
drive no I don't I'm staying here thank
you so much for being here so excited to
hear more new music from you as always
hey this is Ashanti thank you guys so
much for watching we had a blast today
and always remember to drink responsibly
do not drink and drive
[Music]
you